yo yo yo brandon schlobs and theo thongs
what's up man
georgia got a little halloween debate
club for you gentlemen
uh when y'all were younger going trick
or treating and getting them sweet
hitters with your boys
did you keep the pillow that [ __ ]
ass little bucket that your boys had
had to go home and dump it and come back
let me know what you guys think
you took that i love everything that's
all done gang gang buzz buzz
spooky season spooky seasons
i feel like this man has eyeliner bro
quit looking at his eyes that much
though
he's got eyeliner you seem
green or gay is that a banana in your
suit
unless you come with a cucumber in the
front huh you're like does this guy die
his tongue it's like another guy that
guy skins made out of porcelain am i
right fellas
uh no i don't know is this guy wearing a
filter
is this rio de janeiro what's going on
it's jakarta damn
dude carter ready over there chappelle
looks like the lead singer of uh
parliament funkadelic right there
can you bring george oh yeah he does oh
tommy
hey come on now tell mo
holiday inn is that george clinton no
that's [ __ ] but i know that song damn
bro
yeah i'll take that he looks like george
clinton if we open up his
[ __ ] casket right now
why
yeah i'm walking out what's outside with
this you like brave clinton bro
great clue damn bro
george clinton is a legend he's from
virginia wow
he's a legend bro oh what north carolina
kannapolis
what were you saying about that
gentleman nick before you fell in love
well personally we we use the pillowcase
because uh there was halloween but then
there was the weekend before halloween
where we went to nursing homes
and they were all like there was like
three of them in a row and you just went
up and down the hallways it was way more
efficient you'd fill up an
entire pillow and then old timers get
full candy bars now
and you can go around twice some don't
even know hell yeah yeah
yeah wow oh yeah pillowcase all day
yeah that little [ __ ] mop bucket get
the hell out of here man
i'd feel that pillow case i bought it to
them [ __ ] we had that mop bucket
sometimes
really yeah dude the problem with the my
bucket if that handle broke and then you
had to carry the bucket just with your
arms
yeah like a kettlebell yeah that thing
was heavy man
what else do we have oh we got that the
old school one with just the
whatever this was when you were like a
little kid it was a pumpkin you know
like a little tiny one some kid in our
school got his head hidden
stuck in a pumpkin and uh
and yeah he was in the like the little
parking area at the school and somebody
slammed the [ __ ] pumpkin
it was like a series of events into a
[ __ ] close-up car door on it and it
like saved him because of the pumpkin
was on his head
but he put his head fully into a pumpkin
real tight i'll tell you what that's
what we had right there
that shit's weak i'll tell you i'll tell
you
i'll tell you what's up just you know
what he said that's what we have
brothers i like pillowcases doctors you
feel that [ __ ] up to the brim and they
don't
break they heard about their pillow
brendan would hook a handle onto his
cheeks and just open it
yeah insert
[Laughter]
insert only dog
so what's a beautiful man want to know
pillowcase i don't know if we did
pillowcase
i don't know anyone that did anything
else because you could fit so much more
candy in there
and then them dumbasses who would leave
a giant thing of candy out
with a sign because they're late
i'm seven yeah i'm taking all your kids
i'm taking one for the team bro yeah by
team i mean
ear buddy yeah and then you break their
window too
yell the n word in there oh wow okay
that's that new orleans halloween all
right yeah more more trick
more tricking you know i remember some
dumb [ __ ] at the end of my street would
give us uh
pennies oh yeah throw them [ __ ] you
trying to get the [ __ ] on your
like that not for high school we did no
you didn't that was like
for halloween you would do it just for
as [ __ ] we did it as fun but not for
halloween
i don't know kind of [ __ ] does it on
a holiday you get the apple you give
them an egg
it's different i think yeah we used to i
remember one year we got up on the roof
and this fella named pug we had a fella
in our neighborhood named pug
you know named after the animal because
he was really a handsome fella
his he had like a very flat face yeah
that plateau face yeah
you and him could amend the middle you
think oh yeah yeah
we could if we had a child who would
have a perfect news
so he had an innie you know when you
came to notices
and uh we'd get on the roof and shoot
pellet guns at him we'd invite him over
on halloween
and he come across the street and we
just lay into him or
pop off six or eight into him bro he had
skin that was perfect for
taking pellets though oh okay some
people that burned and leaves up
he had that skin oh he had that cajun
skin on him man yeah hell yeah
then it's fun doc how about i ask my mom
i said uh because nick asks
hey can you can you get that uh the
french robot costume again for the show
i was like oh let me hit up my mom so
text my mom's day
hey mama can you make me that french
robot costume she said no
just straight up now i was like okay
not even a negotiation well dude she'd
have to get a lot of fabric you know
what i'm saying bro
you can do it you know what i'm saying
yeah jim you would halloween big around
your neighborhood in san antonio
in texas uh i can't remember too much
about halloween i remember doing stuff
walking around the neighborhood and
stuff but i don't know why anybody why
does everybody have ct in this
[ __ ] walking around the
neighborhood what are you a [ __ ]
hitchhiker dude do you remember
halloween
brendan right there dude dog in there me
and jazz there's a [ __ ]
one's a tiger one's a [ __ ] ninja
oh you look like your son right yeah
yeah
you really do my twin there's tiger's
buzz right here
and that's the same costume that fit me
last year you guys do look
a lot of like crazy tiger's insane
though man tiger's on what
he's on uppers or something yeah he's on
something besides
uh juice boxes right now
the boy that novitskiy needs to test
that young